sally unlvs the rebel girls and company
are hoping to snag their ninth win at
their next competition in april but they
can't do it alone mary jane belliesa
shares how the team is preparing and how
you can help
unlv's competitive dance team the rebel
girls and company are hoping to compete
at the international cheer union in
florida head captain gage johnson says
the team is representing as the u.s
national premier hip-hop team this year
we had this opportunity to compete at
icu worlds about two years ago and then
right when cope would happen it was
sadly taken away so we're actually super
excited to have this opportunity again
college junior cassidy turland says
getting there is just half the battle
the team hopes donations through their
rebel razor event will cover their
travel costs we have different donation
amounts you can make anywhere from
twenty five dollars to as much as you'd
like really and what's really cool about
it is it lets you know like what you're
donating for unlv's the rebel girls and
company have won eight competitions so
far and they're practicing for eight
hours a day as they get ready for their
next competition in april and make sure
that whatever we put on the stage is our
is our very best and so we usually come
in with like a list to do and we'll stay
until we get everything done and so when
we are at florida we're at our peak and
write our best turlan says trust is key
when it comes to execution and
perfecting every move we also have to
like trust that the leaders on this team
have been put in that position for a
reason and trust our coaches they have
our best interest in mind and even
though hours get long we kind of have to
understand that
being here is for a reason all more of a
reason with the goal to win mary jane
balleza live local now
if you'd like to learn more about the
team's rebel razor we have a link for
you on our website that's 8 news now dot
com
coming up next